auf und davon spezial wird ihnen
präsentiert von kinder schokolade
sechs jahre sind monika lehnert und
kurzentschlossen abruf kambodscha
romário hat schon die erste problem
bevor mir dein geld wählen
portmonee und sich durchgesetzt
gut für start-ups gästehaus aber
konkurrenz wird die mauer
die machen sich kaputt gegenseitig mit
mich dass sie dass sie krisen zerbrochen
der peter besseres budget mit und reisen
obwohl sich mit handy um fürs für sie
nicht auch wehren
moni dienste wirklich möglich eine
hängematte ich mich die haie
geld muss
der sieger
[Musik]
die geschichte fängt ganz anders als
maria ward ich bin die muss land sondern
in der schweiz unterwegs
brienz im berner oberland ich muss zu
zart bahnhofs brienzer rothorn fahrt der
petri sie hat mit angestellt er ist für
sp schweiz ordnung für sich schnuppertag
will ich im moment auf der suche nach
form und wird das auch in 2010 groß sie
zur rede hält
pünktlich los in richtung peter bewirbt
sich da als zugbegleiter eine
angestellte vor der roten bahn erklärt
und so vergleichen gibt es da ja allein
im prinzip fertig gestellt
für disney die vestische innere werte
der peter wild geschäftskonto john über
gut laufen es war mit viel weniger
westliche touristen und die regensaison
leiter peter duft rom brauchte unbedingt
dass wieder zwei jahren aber durchziehen
und den drittel haben und sagen jetzt
ist das jahr vor das büro und wohnung so
viel freude aber jetzt ist eine zeit für
alles und mit nur wenig gepäck wandern
peter kruse wo die kal ihren hut 2011
aus von diesem moment träumte monika
schon seit ihren welt stand ja
und jetzt
die heimmannschaft
siag will kambodscha 200 meter vom meer
entfernt steht das gasthaus wiesbaden
doch gehört es aber nicht moneo peter
sondern dem vormieter max bevor der
vertrag unterschrieben ist gibt's auch
schon erste problem
so ernst die lage schon locker gehen die
beiden schweizer damit ohne sie finden
eine einigung mit dem vermieter ohne
mehr zu bezahlen als abgemacht dass
guest house gehört nun offiziell
sie haben noch nicht alle zimmer gesehen
und merken vorgänger max hat alles
verlottern lassen wenn ich vor erstmal
kaum geld und viele baustellen die
beiden tun was sie können
renovieren und lassen den vorplatz mit
neuen platten verlegen
doch einen tag vor der eröffnung bahnt
sich schon das nächste unheil an
alles okay das heiße wasser ist kaputt
auch das noch ein gast hat sich
beschwert
die angestellte tui soll einen neuen
boiler kaufen
bisher hat moni und peter noe ausgaben
jetzt soll endlich auch etwas
hereinkommen
als das gasthaus zum ersten mal
ausgebucht ist kommt peter beim
zubereiten des frühstücks an seine
grenzen
trotz aller widrigkeiten ist das projekt
swiss garten ein voller erfolg die gäste
kommen den schaden
es läuft so gut dass moni und peter
expandieren wollen macht gleich zwei
häuser für den ex trug begleiter und die
einstige modeberaterin eine
erfolgsgeschichte
wir sind beide einfach so der
durchschnitt schweizer und
schweizerinnen riesige budgets komme ich
aber es ist noch machbar
[Musik]
vier jahre später leppert monierte peter
immer noch im dialog will am meer knapp
33 euro die fünftgrößte stadt vom land
[Musik]
da bin i und tricks zum gruße finde warf
sich im liebeswahn der andere teil
für piccards oder goldige neue im
wolfcenter stand
[Musik]
daum suisse golden quarry für bi der
sägemühle zwingt hp xml direktes will
nach oben also zu dem rohbau gesehen
perfekt banking 26
ich hab dich verboten hallo
ich kann das mit fünfzehn mal hat story
das wis wähler vor wonach moni und peter
selber die andere sind im moment alle
touristen formierte frühstück kein
problem wir haben spieler oder rohe eier
oder ein schinken käse omelett oder
fruchtsalat heute geht er den strand
jäger ströme durch taiwan aber so
stempfle und moni hauptsächlich lustig
wie viel ich immer wieder dass zum
beispiel hat früher noch so ins
wiesbaden biene ferien gemacht
[Musik]
da hat sich doch ab morgen
der täter muss sich nun mit holte im
schnitt genau mühe machen und ich sage
zwei jahre gestellt
das humble stand
kontakt zu seinen gästen peter wichtig
besonders die richtige daumen und
interlaken betreut
sie ist 81 und vietnam kambodscha sales
nur magazin look will
darum hat sie für rund 30 frank hat in
peter mehrtägige rundreisen auf die
rundreise wendt moni und petri zukunft
setzen wir bringen wenigstens noch viel
geld aber was ist mit ihrem gästehaus wo
sie sagen hätten
und zwar wie man will aber zurück land
wo man selber wohnen und 90 euro und
reisen
neben der schweiz sind und im endeffekt
ich sollte einfach höchstens fällt so
hat er vor zwei jahren
ich drücke zusätzlich weil die
getriebene tonanlage scb geist und moni
da hatten wir so loacker und im ski-ort
morgen steht sie aber offenbar mit der
hand und dann ist er ganz vage da und
damit auch ins tor stellen aber auch
dann nicht dass daniel v wurde bis sie
hofft das funktioniert nicht und du hast
das mit der web seite aus und reißt alte
was sowieso da rundreise das ist das
land wirklich bringt finanziell als
gäste aus velbert und johannes karten
ausgeliefert und andere
es sieht alles gut aus sie entlässt sie
ein das wunderschön muss sie eine neue
geschäftsidee und krieg krämpfe moni und
peter dort kambodscha ums überleben
wo genau liegt eigentliches problem
extrem viel verändert es sind derart
hoch dass wiesbaden ist super das hat
die der letzten zwei jahre abgeben mit
dem westlicher tourismus ich fühle mich
wirklich heiß sie sind zwischen wir nach
new york hast du trusts immer mehr unter
30 dollar und dafür hast du er kommt
immer mit klimaanlage für die machen
sich kaputt gegenseitig mit dass sie
dass sie krisen zu trocknen weihnachts
und lehre stil wird weitermachen werde
zwar dass wenn wir jetzt werden wir
wirklich gern in kambodscha liebe warum
hat das geklappt aus was wird eigentlich
immer darum möchten sich beworben
pixie lott ist neu und soll die stellung
sie haben das 60 prozent steht im
endeffekt afrika weniger forsch wenig
weniger bezahlen aber wirklich aus zu
erfolg und auf der andere sieht im
grandhotel giessbach vision.de gersbach
und definition die märz bis oktober
dafür die märkte andere lösung
[Musik]
und das macht die zukunft wird lang und
immer zweimal bitten
biete fort dort stadthalle beim zuerst
die unzählige casino kursaals neue las
vegas wo sie die stars hier werden es
herrscht goldgräberstimmung chinesen ein
ziel für sich entdeckt dafür bliebe die
westliche touristen immer mehr überall
sind großbaustelle chinesische
investoren des gordon ehemalige
gästehaus von moni und peter ich spüre
noch frei gestanden
jetzt wird fast erdrückt und neue
riesige hotelanlagen gute neue betrieb
um suisse group suchen schweizer des
gordon ich jetzt gerade das buch hat
aber der größte teil vom jahres anders
silvia schneider muss in der nebensaison
ins geschäft für das land sieht darin so
viele tore zu schießen
und mittlerweile ist so dass wir noch
sehen die wahl baut wird als in den
ersten paar jahre so viel hotelbau der
herrscht der geist 257 wir waschen
überleben nicht nur moni und peter sind
also am krämpfen zukunft für linie
pensionen
sie tragen schwarz
[Musik]
roddick trifft mir die heimische am
strand
peter und monika sich einen gemeinsamen
a big gefordert peter schon wieder 34
[Musik]
das ist musik also ich hab gesagt kleine
tier spitze sagte vor gericht ich habe
mich mega ja das wird jetzt schon dass
mir bewusst wie bisher denn gott ich bin
ja jetzt schon weil ich nur daran denken
dass er am 24 02 2010 geschafft hätte
den mietern habe ich kein problem
naja
[Musik]
nom penh kambodscha sie liegt im land
us-dollar rund zwei millionen menschen
[Musik]
der peter ist nun unterwegs mit dem gar
story straße aus interlaken auf der
rundreise in die neue heimat kambodscha
führt er sie ort wo man garantiert mit
der reiseführer findet
[Musik]
unterwegs ist er am liebsten tut also
leer im land und lud am besten kennen
seiten bedruckt lori sie reist mit einer
dach und umwelt und ruhe bringen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das sind ja
ich sehe gar nicht erst ende juni war
sie stark das ist logisch dass ich
gesperrt werde
die schöne brünette waren die aktie
jetzt mit ihr gesprochen
was willst du dann noch uri für havel
nichts wenn wir vorher bedarf zum eine
buddhistische tempel bison nächste
station
[Musik]
in dialog will macht monien spaziergang
mit ihren zwei höhen celina und st
gerade um die ecke wo das wis villa
staates improvisierte dorf und das
instituto die straßen und machten und
der straße
es ist auf der baustelle ist also vom
jüngsten baby bis zum großvater
großmutter helfen alle mit
das ist glichen im straßenbau die wohn
oder der straße entlang
seine unterstützer nachher kambodschas
von der ärmsten länder von asien ein
fünftel von der lueg nur für 1 franken
pro tag
die websuche buddhistische tempel
erwartet man eigentlich ruhe und
besinnlichkeit
aber schumi gang werden auf einer
übereifrigen tempel der in beschlag
[Musik]
petersburg dies trägt die berge zu sehen
ist und befreit schließlich
[Musik]
moni hat ihren lebensrhythmus ganz
statische kultura passt sie planen nur
groß sondern lebt im moment andersen
peter ich seh schon fast so
kambodschanerin wurde und sehr doch auch
freunde gefunden
geht's euch gut ja uns geht es gut wir
wollten nur schnell hallo sagen wir
haben uns schon so lange nicht mehr
gesehen
krämer ist harmonie ihres gewinns die
clinique aria ist dass reto ihre tochter
harmonie ihre erste angestellt x.com
butscher wo sie dass louis golden
verkauft und ist retweetet blieben
trotzdem und die zwei frauen immer noch
engen kontakt für machten aber mehr
erhält weil ich von ihr rede sage ich
nicht ich besuche meine ehemalige chefin
sondern meine familie
wir helfen uns gegenseitig wenn es
probleme gibt
sie hängen dicke buch hat monique seit
sie rät sprach vor der heimische mehr so
recht gut im königreich vor der wunder -
als quasi heißt dass er mit mir schon
bald spüren über frühen morgen
wir sind auf dem bahnhof phnom penh
daran ist so groß dass neun zusätzliche
wagen musik hängt werde
für die meisten dauer wird die erste
zugfahrt vor ihrem leben
der zug war das sieht man ja wieder und
auch das nur am wochenende trotz der
vielen fahrgästen wie sie mir krank
strafraum stumm für sichere dienste
peter er hat wird loren am noch ob es
speziell vorbereitet
das ist clean scouts stern zuvor bereits
durch der wagen vor der königin also
mutter vom aktuelle könig und damit
einfach die ganze woche wieder andere
wechselt platzverhältnisse wenig ratlos
und das sind da noch lange da wie ich
stecke ich habe auch ein hit für diesen
wagen
das weiß ich doch nicht fragt das
personal ich habe gefragt ist ein fehler
passiert
ich habe mein typ doch er steht doch das
gleiche siehst du aber es ist nicht der
gleiche waren noch 61
das ist eigentlich das problem ich habe
300 dollar für den ganzen wagen bezahlt
das ist nicht die schützen zu lassen
die hand braut vor nummer posten sägen
welche gründe hat
ich habe ja gesagt 300 dollar für den
raum aber auch sagen diese gestartet
worden
derzeit ist sich sicher dass die platz
ja das ist nur dieses problem ganz
bestimmt
damit ist das ja nicht aus italien der
dollar vor
ich bin erst zufrieden wenn ihr mir 200
dollar zurück gibt ich zahle doch nicht
für all diese leute
dabei schien sich durchsetzen alles wird
wieder risiko mit hut noch nie
und so hat lori resolut deren cockpit
und die umwelt engagement musik peter
mooney das wies wieder alles ruhig um
den sport
[Musik]
zurück zum zug sneijder hauptstadt vor
über eine stunde hätte modellen abfahre
abo bestellen die mono am bahnhof ist
dass die tickets sind aber ziemlich
verrückt dass ich mich überraschen
es ist voll da vorne
während peter drunter und drüber gott
bringt seine freundin monyetta swiss
will ein mythos der ruhe die hängematte
hochlagen was super ist wegen
durchblutungsstörungen dabei musste man
sich schon im schlimmsten fall geht zu
stoffen die wunderbar schnell heilen
wenn bei gut sehr gut sogar
bis jetzt
und das hat die ig bau in einer
hängematte meditation zu verdanken
[Applaus]
regisseur denkt aber wir fahren endlich
mit einer stunde und zehn minuten
verspätete anreise und villa 203
wie sie und beten gäste wie sie reisen
die der ärger verraucht
17 personen vor dem frühstück stehen sie
als logisch wenn dadurch auch sorge für
die ich lese er schon auch ein hausdach
muss gehoben
[Musik]
ich bin doch wir müssen auch immer
versehen
[Musik]
und so verlauf der rechten wurde sie
bestehende zug war dialog will ruhig und
erholsam friedlich schlummern amerika
[Musik]
jetzt ist beim pisa quelle
das vila vita moni und peter die high
stelle fest dass die zwei aber doch die
heile schweizer sind sogar die
kambodschanische nachstellt einschub
lernt wie man eine schweizer von die
macht
ich bin ja in kambodscha gestoppt 50 die
spitze 50 geht es ja du 48
ich bin mir zwar macht du musst eine
rhetorische haben also die kulturnacht
am allerwenigsten rechtlich überhaupt
nicht mehr gut auf einmal für 100 dollar
vor steuern und nach regeln wollte
wissen was wir machen hat die arbeit
widrige umstände sagt mit einem
galgenhumor ich mir selber
[Gelächter]
also ich alle die jetzt der schlechten
charakter hat sich der täter am kopf
gemacht und was passiert und was ist
wenn und was ist wenn und wann sich wenn
und dann einfach mit zur ruhe auf die
zwetschge dank
er hatte sich sorgen gemacht hat und nur
sie jetzt ich habe mir selbst gemacht wo
ich einen job politische jetzt dass ich
mich größte problem sei das ist
eigentlich so wie ich die nachricht sie
wo die am besten in europa so die
schweiz wechseln wollen job die nächsten
sieben minute für die ende mai auf geld
das ist ganz logisch aber für jenen so
viel dass man die sim lock und
überbrücken
also wahrscheinlich zu machen von dem
her oder die jetzt sieht das wird dann
mehr als genug
das ist rennsport man auch an der peter
und monzingen sich tränen damit sie
weitere gemeinsame zukunft 1 kambodscha
für das die schiene kreisels groß
vor zwei wochen später gemeldet also je
zwei zaubertoren gut und fit moni
stimmig besetzt
die st
[Musik]
merkst buchholz auf schweden
ferienanlage von daniel schafer und
carolin schneider
es war die kombination von sechs jahren
sind gaulin und der daniel die firmen
schritte hinter flattr
die größte neuigkeit ich liebte die da
die beiden auswanderer sind unerwartet
neue ein fries ist das so
[Musik]
auf und davon spezial wurde ihnen
präsentiert von kinder schokolade